- WHOA.
[laughs]
HI.
THAT WASN'T--
EXPECTED TO SEE YOU
ALL UNDULATIN' UP HERE.
UH, HI.
I JUST PUT MY JACKET
ON THE BED
WHEN I FIRST CAME
TO THE PARTY,
BUT I DIDN'T REALIZE
THAT THE PARTY
MADE ITS WAY
UP HERE.
BUT I'LL GET
THAT NOW.
I WILL, IF YOU--
CAROL, I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'RE IN THERE SOMEWHERE,
BUT WHEREVER YOU ARE,
THANK YOU
FOR THE INVITATION.
I REALLY ENJOYED MYSELF.
I'LL SEE YOU
AT WORK TOMORROW.
OKAY, HEY, SIR, I THINK
I SEE MY JACKET.
I THINK--I THINK YOUR ARM
IS IN THE SLEEVE, ACTUALLY.
I'LL GRAB--
THAT'S NOT MY JACKET,
AND THAT'S
NOT YOUR ARM.
IT'S NOT YOUR ARM.
WHITE PEOPLE ARE CRAZY.
JUST LOOKIN' FOR A JACKET.
SIR, OKAY, YES,
VERY NICE MUSTACHE.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ONE
ABOVE THE NOSE.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
THAT'S NOT YOUR NOSE.
OKAY, SORRY
TO DISTURB YOU, SIR.
JUST LOOKIN' FOR
A JACKET,
JUST A ORDINARY MAN
LOOKIN' FOR A JACKET.
YOU WANNA SAY SOMETHING
TO ME, SIR?
ARE YOU TRY--
OH, WAIT A MINUTE.
MM-MM.
NO, THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SIR.
IT TASTED A LITTLE BIT
LIKE SALTY BUTT HOLE,
BUT THAT'S OKAY.
IT'S TWEED,
THE JACKET I'M TALKING ABOUT,
AND IT'S GOT LEATHER PATCHES
ON IT.
JUST--OH, MAYBE
THIS IS IT.
THANK YOU, FOUND IT, AND--
NOPE, THAT'S NOT IT,
BUT CONGRATULATIONS, MA'AM.
YOU ARE DOING GREAT
WITH WHAT GOD GAVE YOU.
NOPE, DON'T LOOK AT ME
IN THE EYES, MA'AM.
I DON'T WANT YOU
TO STEAL MY SOUL.
HI, LADIES.
VERY NICE TO MEET YOU.
AND, SIR,
YES, I DO SEE YOU TOO.
OKAY, YES.
WHITE PEOPLE ARE CRAZY.
OH, NO, I'M--I'M OKAY.
I REALLY AM.
I'M ALREADY SEEING
A-A GROUP OF PEOPLE,
AND WE'RE
TAKING IT SLOWLY.
WE ARE
IT'S A CHURCH.
MAYBE SOME OF Y'ALL
WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN LOOKING INTO THAT.
NOT MINE,
BUT ONE SOMEWHERE,
IF THAT'S--
OKAY, THANK YOU, MA'AM, FOR--
THERE IT IS.
I FOUND IT.
FOUND THE JACKET.
IT'S RIGHT HERE.
I'MA PULL IT,
AND I BELIEVE
IT MIGHT BE LOST SOMEWHERE
WITHIN YOU.
I'M JUST GUESSING
BECAUSE THAT
IS JUST A LITTLE BIT
OF RESISTANCE.
ALL RIGHT,
THERE WE GO.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT IS GOING TO BE YOURS.
KEEP IT, THANK YOU.
COVER YOURSELVES UP.
CAROL, IF YOU'RE
IN THERE,
I'LL SEE YOU
AT THE OFFICE TOMORROW.
JUST BRING THE BOWL.
YOU CAN FINISH THE EGG SALAD.
MY GOD,
WHITE PEOPLE CRAZY.